[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat de France 24 on
va s'arrêter ce soir sur la situation à
l'est de la République démocratique du
Congo il y a 10 ans tout juste les
rebelles du M2300 paraît de Goma et bien
aujourd'hui la même rébellion est à
seulement quelques kilomètres de la
capitale du Nord qui vous les civils de
la région vivent dans la crainte de
nouvelles exactions des dizaines de
milliers d'entre eux ont déjà été
déplacés la République démocratique du
Congo accuse le Rwanda de soutenir le
M23 cette rébellion a dominante Tutsi ce
que Kigali dément alors qu'elle est
vraiment le rôle de Kigali l'annonce par
le Kenya hier d'envoi de troupes pour
stopper ces rebelles pourra-t-elle
changer la donne quel rôle peut jouer la
communauté internationale qui depuis
plusieurs jours condamnent les actions
du M23 dans cette région va en débattre
avec nos invités ce soir en plateau
doudou Sidibé enseignant chercheur en
sciences politiques à l'université
Gustave Eiffel bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous parce Skype de Goma pierre
Boisselet corde coordonnateur des
recherches sur la violence à ébutelli
une structure partenaire de recherche du
groupe d'études sur le Congo à
l'université de New York pierre
Boisselet bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous et puis on Skype depuis Liège
en Belgique
Bobba professeur en sciences politiques
spécialiste notamment de cette région et
de la résolution des conflits et puis on
retrouve un petit peu plus tard
on retrouvera depuis Kinshasa Raphaël
Piret il est représentant de Médecins
sans frontières mais on le retrouvera un
petit peu plus tard dans ce débat
j'aimerais d'abord qu'on aille à
Kinshasa faire un point sur la situation
sur le terrain pour ça on va retrouver
notre correspondante Aurélie bazarra qui
bangoula Aurélie bonsoir le M23 poursuit
son avancée vers Goma quel est
exactement la situation aujourd'hui
alors cette semaine on observe une
relative à calmée dans l'est du pays des
sources locales nous renseignent
qu'elles n'entendent plus de
bombardements intenses comme ceux de la
semaine dernière samedi le M23 avait
pris le contrôle de deux localités qui
one déjà et roule chou rousse centre
c'est de localités sont stratégiques car
elles sont proches de Larousse Nationale
2 un axe qui dessert Goma le chef-lieu
de la province du Nord qui vous
maintenant des sources sécuritaires nous
expliquent que le M23 progresserait vers
le nord de la province en territoire de
ruchourou et les forces armées
congolaises elles semblent positionner
non loin de la route nationale 2 pour
empêcher toute avancer du M23 vers Goma
pour la pour rappel pardon le M23
contrôle aussi depuis presque 5 mois
maintenant la cité commerciale de
bounagana située à la frontière avec
l'Ouganda une cité stratégique avec une
route commerciale très fréquentée pour
l'instant il est difficile d'avoir un
bilan humain précis de ses affrontements
les autorités congolaise parle d'au
moins 10 civile tu es selon les Nations
Unies
près plus pardon plus de 70 000
personnes ont fui leur localité pour se
réfugier dans des sites de déplacés aux
abords de Goma la communauté
internationale appelle à des
négociations entre le gouvernement
congolais le groupe armé du M23 mais
aussi des négociations avec le Rwanda
car Kinshasa accuse le Rwanda de
soutenir le M23 les autorités
congolaises ici à Kinshasa parle
d'agression rwandaise et multiplient les
appels envers la communauté
internationale pour lui demander de
sanctionner le Rwanda Kinshasa refuse
toujours de négocier avec le M23 et
efface à l'avancée du M23 la population
elle multiplie ces derniers jours les
manifestations de colère
oui effectivement mardi un convoi de la
Monusco en provenance de roumaine gabot
a été pris pour cible par la population
un point de contrôle des forces armées
congolaises à quelques kilomètres de
Goma un camion a été brûlé en signe de
colère car pour la plupart des habitants
de l'Est le sentiment d'abandon et grand
la veille lundi plusieurs milliers de
personnes sont descendues dans les rues
de Goma à l'appel de la société civile
tout son dénoncés le Rwanda et son
président Paul Kagame accusé de soutenir
le M23 des accusations que Kigali a
toujours démenti des manifestations ont
aussi éclaté à Bukavu et comme à Goma
les manifestants scander des champs pour
demander aux autorités congolaises
d'armée les civils pour se défendre car
de plus en plus d'habitants de l'Est du
pays remettent en cause les capacités
des forces armées congolaises à faire
face au M23 aujourd'hui le ministre de
la Défense Gibert Kabanda a fait le
déplacement à Goma pour faire selon les
autorités l'inspection des opérations
militaires sur le terrain est montré la
volonté du gouvernement à reprendre le
contrôle dans l'est du pays une reprise
de contrôle qui passe notamment pour les
autorités congolaises par le déploiement
des forces kenyan après avoir été
réticent le Kenya a finalement confirmé
que ses troupes sont prêtes à être
envoyés au Congo dans le cadre de la
force régionale de la communauté
d'Afrique de l'Est restent maintenant à
déterminer le calendrier de ce
déploiement et à régler l'épineuse
question du financement de cette force
régionale ça on en reparlera tout à
l'heure avec notre correspondant à un
aérobie merci beaucoup Aurélie bazarra
qui bangoula depuis Kinshasa donc voilà
un peu pour le tableau ce qui se passe
en ce moment pierre Boisselet avant
qu'on revienne sur ses accusations qui
visent Kigali j'aimerais que vous vous
reveniez sur sur les débuts de cette
offensive du M23 offensif qui a repris
le 20 octobre dernier est-ce qu'il y a
eu un élément le déclencheur
alors c'est assez difficile de savoir
avec précision quel est quel était
l'élément déclencheur d'ailleurs on ne
sait pas exactement qui a repris les
affrontements dans ce genre de
circonstances c'est toujours très
difficile
d'en être certain on peut formuler quand
même quelques hypothèses alors
dans les jours qui ont précédé la
reprise de ces affrontements les
autorités congolaises notamment par la
voix de Serge tibangou qui est chargé
des négociations avec les groupes armés
avait dit que
on ne négocierait pas il avait il avait
dit une nouvelle fois mais c'était la
première fois depuis quelques temps que
on négocierait pas
et que donc par conséquent notamment il
ne devrait pas être convié à la nouvelle
réunion qui devait se tenir un aérobie
le 4 novembre donc ça devait être demain
mais ça a été reporté de 15 jours et
voilà on sait que le le M23 depuis
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant demande
des négociations directes avec le
gouvernement congolais donc ça a pu être
un des facteurs déclencheurs ce qu'il
faut dire aussi c'est que ça fait aussi
plusieurs
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois que
les autorités congolaises se sont donnés
pour objectif de reprendre du territoire
om23 et notamment
le poste frontière de bounagana qui a
été évoqué par Aurélie bazark qui
bangoula et donc
ça bon il y avait aussi une volonté
probablement de d'en découdre du côté
des autorités
congolaises mais si certains en tout cas
c'est que les affrontements ont
clairement tourné à l'avantage du M23
depuis le 20 novembre c'est très
baignant a quasiment doublé le
territoire qu'il contrôlait et a pris
effectivement des des endroits
stratégiques
du territoire de ruthu au nord comment
appliquer cette déroute de l'armée
congolaise
malheureusement merci pour la question
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que l'armée
puisque l'armée congolaise est une armée
composée de différents groupes armées et
ces différents groupes armées non jamais
pu constituer une un seul
groupe un seul corps malheureusement
c'est là où on en est
voilà un petit problème de liaison avec
Bob cabamba doudou Sidibé je vous posais
la question
pourquoi ça te déroute de l'armée
congolaise face au M23 aujourd'hui
comme le disait tout à l'heure mon
collègue l'armée congolaise est très
très fragile même aidé par la Monique
l'armée congolaise n'a jamais réussi à
éradiquer cette rébellion qui qui
sévit dans le dans le dans le qui vous
dans le qui vous et qui depuis très
longtemps disons que c'est la résultante
d'un conflit qui a été mal terminé en
réalité parce que les depuis le conflit
le génocide rwandais qui s'est déporté
sur le territoire congolais et puis qui
a amené des conflits successifs il a eu
des négociations notamment avec les
groupes armés et
Laurent Kunda Laurent Kunda on se
souvient de lui
c'était des solidarisé des accords et
avait créé un groupe qui s'appelait le
CNDP le Congrès nation pour la défense
du peuple et aujourd'hui quand Laurent
kuna a été capturé et emprisonné au
Rwanda le M 23 a été créé sous les
cendres du NDMP voilà et aujourd'hui ce
genre de groupe devrait être combattu on
les appelle des spoilers c'est à dire ce
sont des groupes qui émergent après les
accords de paix maintenant
l'armée congolaise a laissé traîner ce
groupe a repris des forces et
aujourd'hui en train de créer des
problèmes à l'armée congolaise qui n'a
jamais contrôlé cette partie de du pays
et la communauté internationale et
Kinshasa accuse qui guérit de soutenir
ce groupe rebelle du M23 l'ambassadeur
du Rwanda d'ailleurs été expulsé de RDC
c'était ce weekend on va écouter à ce
propos le chef de la diplomatie
congolaise il était l'invité du journal
de l'Afrique hier soir sur France 24
un groupe d'experts commis par les
Nations Unies elles-mêmes a fait un
rapport qui a été déposé en bonne forme
et qu'il atteste est-ce qu'il y a encore
de doute de l'or que Monsieur de
sécurité grand des Nations Unies
terrestres et Madame la représentance
spéciale de ce qui était général en RDC
c'est de hautes autorités de Nations
Unies ont affirmé qu'en fait
dont on nous dit qu'il se bat contre les
phares d'essai est une armée
conventionnelle et une armée puissamment
armée de sorte que le fond de la Monusco
ne peuvent pas la braver le président
Kagame lui-même a la tribune de Nations
Unies au mois de septembre dernier dans
les cadres de la 78e session de
l'Assemblée générale
sans argument se contenter de dire que
il n'y a plus de réclamation à faire
maintenant alors vers une solution qui
est possible et enfin
vous savez que toute la communauté
internationale en tout cas toutes les
institutions internationales qui se sont
pensées sur le dossier ont demandé à la
RDC de négocier
la diplomatie congolaise c'était hier
soir pierre Boisselet qui Galy ni
fermement être impliqué et soutenir le
M23 même s'il y a eu un rapport de l'ONU
aussi qui affirme le contraire à quoi
joue le Rwanda dans ce qui est en train
de se dans ce qui est en train de se
passer à l'Est de la RDC
on aborde personnellement j'ai le
sentiment que le Rwanda ne peut être un
peu moins fermement ce dernier temps
cette implication même si elle reste sur
un démenti
il y a aujourd'hui beaucoup de sources
bon vous avez cité le rapport de l'ONU
mais il y a aussi beaucoup de sources
notamment diplomatiques de l'ONU de
différents pays qui affirme aujourd'hui
que le Rwanda est impliqué et notamment
dans cette dernière phase offensive le
porte-parole de du département d'État
américain là aussi affirmé
donc voilà
c'est difficile de savoir quelle est la
raison fondamentale mais
mais cette application semble
aujourd'hui assez bien
assez bien avéré alors c'est certain
qu'il y a une sympathie
du pouvoir rwandais à l'égard du
Mouvement du 23 mars et c'est aussi
valable qu'il y a eu un certain nombre
de difficultés qui ont été rencontrées
entre le président Félix Tshisekedi et
son homologue Paul Kagame on ne sait pas
exactement
qu'est-ce qui est à l'origine de
l'escalade mais très clairement la
reprise la résurgence du M23
on a un peu de mal à vous entendre
pierre Boisselet on vous retrouvera tout
à l'heure bobcabamba on vous retrouve
pour continuer à parler de ses relations
justement entre
Kinshasa et Kigali jusqu'où peut aller
cette brouille je le disais
l'ambassadeur du Rwanda à Kinshasa a été
expulsé le week-end dernier alors que
Kigali et accusé de soutenir ce
mouvement rebelle est-ce qu'il y a un
risque que ça dégénère entre les deux
pays oui il y a un risque que que je
vais madame puisque on a déjà connu sur
l'histoire c'est qu'on a toujours des
conflits qu'on appelle des conflits
locaux qui ont des répercussions au
niveau régional et lorsqu'il est le
niveau régional prend le pas sur le
local on a l'application des états et 4
mois l'application des états on a
l'application de armées étatique donc il
ne serait pas étonnant que dans les
prochaines semaines que vu la situation
continue d'être bloquée que le Rwanda
soit obligé de pouvoir intervenir
directement sur le territoire congolais
et là nous allons assister véritablement
à un affrontement entre l'armée
congolaise d'une part et d'autre part
l'armée rwandaise avec le M23 mais aussi
faut souligner que quand on parle du
lien entre le 1 2 3 et l'armée rwandaise
faut pas oublier que la partie que le
M23 occupe c'est la partie frontalière
avec l'Ouganda ce n'est pas avec le
Rwanda donc braganha c'est à la
frontière avec le Rwanda
et même l'autre frontière la deuxième
a été pris par le M23 c'est aussi un
poste avec la frontière avec l'Ouganda
et là aussi il faut être attentif par
rapport aux jeux qui vont se jouer entre
d'une part le Rwanda et lougan par
rapport au rapport de tous les deux pays
Ouganda Rwanda vont avoir avec le Congo
surtout avec le régime de Félix
Tshisekedi
génère au niveau régional oui il y a des
risques parce que si les forces armées
rwandaises traversent la frontière pour
continuer à soutenir comme on le dit le
M23 forcément le gouvernement congolais
n'accepterait pas sera forcément obligé
de réagir et ça peut créer une conflit
régional comme on en a vu il y a
quelques années de cela et ce serait
dommage et là il faut peut-être prôner
une certaine coopération parce que c'est
déjà arrivé parce que Laurent Kunda qui
a
enfanter ce mouvement là était aussi la
cause il y a quelques années et les deux
pays se sont
coopérer pour pouvoir
prendre le recula et l'amener en prison
je pense que les deux pays peuvent
réitérer cela pour éviter en conflit
entre
en tout cas pour l'instant le M23 est
donc tout prêt de la ville de Goma et
les civils sont les premiers à payer le
prix de cette avancée en 11 jours ça
c'était en début de semaine l'ONU
annonçait que ses combats avaient fait
quelques 50000 déplacés on va regarder à
ce propos le reportage de notre
correspondante tournée il y a quelques
jours et puis on en reparle après
c'est une école transformée en site
d'accueil à une dizaine de kilomètres de
Goma le site de Bonga accueille près de
20 000 hommes femmes et enfants tous
sont venus se mettre à l'abri des tirs
et des bombardements sur chaque visage
la peur mais aussi la fatigue pas je
suis venu de Camember j'ai fui la guerre
entre le M23 et l'armée il
s'affrontaient dans notre village nous
avons entendu beaucoup de tirs et nous
avons fuit vers rougarie mais la
situation s'est aggravée nous avons été
obligés de fuir à pied pour venir ici
dans l'urgence cette agricultrice n'a
rien emporté avec elle
depuis que nous sommes arrivés ici nous
n'avons pas encore trouvé de la
nourriture les enfants tombent malades
parfois nous les amenons au centre de
santé mais à cause de la guerre ils
guérissent difficilement ils ne sont pas
en bonne santé nous dormons très mal à
donner les humanitaires sur place se
disent préoccupés par la poursuite des
combats chaque jour de nouvelles
familles arrivent sur le site pour se
réfugier
nous ne savons pas où nous allons
diriger les déplacés ni ce qu'ils vont
manger la situation est vraiment très
précaire les conditions de vie sont
déplorables nous avons déjà enterré 14
personnes et d'autres déplacées viennent
d'arriver nous avons peur car nous
allons continuer à enterrer d'autres
personnes depuis la reprise des combats
c'est une véritable marée humaine qui
déferle sur Goma en une semaine près de
40 000 congolais ce sont déplacés selon
les Nations Unies les autorités
congolaises mais aussi le groupe
d'experts des Nations Unies sur la RDC
accuse le Rwanda d'appuyer le M23 Kigali
continue à nier tout soutien ce groupe
armé
Raphaël Piret représentant de Médecins
sans frontières en RDC nous a rejoint
Raphaël Piret bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous on vient de le voir
dans le reportage la situation est
extrêmement compliqué pour les civils
ils sont les premières victimes de ces
combats
effectivement
ce qu'on constate c'est des nouveaux
déplacements massif de population il
faut savoir qu'il y avait déjà plus de
200 000 personnes déplacées ces derniers
mois dans le cadre de cette de cette
crise et des affrontements certains aux
alentours du territoire de retour où ont
lieu les combats d'autres plus au sud
vers Goma et depuis l'intentification
des combats fin octobre on constate que
de nombreuses personnes qui leur village
ou déserte les Candes déplacées dans le
Nord pour se diriger vers le sud plus
près de Goma par exemple à Canet
ruchinia a une dizaine de kilomètres au
nord de Goma plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes sont arrivées pour
se mettre à l'abri dans des sites
informel cette localité accueille déjà
des dizaines de milliers de déplacés
depuis plusieurs mois et les conditions
de vie étaient déjà extrêmement
précaires comme vous l'avez vu dans leur
portage l'arrivée d'une nouvelle vague
de personnes déplacées à croire encore
significativement les besoins il faut
s'imaginer la situation pour ces gens en
l'espace de quelques jours c'est des
milliers on arrive qui viennent
s'installer dans les sites collectifs
comme vous l'avez vu dans des écoles ou
des églises mais mes collègues me
disaient encore cet après-midi le plus
souvent il se retrouve dans des abris de
fortune quand tu es à la hâte avec des
branchages des feuilles de Calyptus ils
ont ramassé sur la route ou dans les
forêts avoisinantes tout ça après avoir
marché pendant des heures et des heures
pour pour arriver jusque là
les chiffres sont pas encore très clairs
mais ce qui est clair c'est que ces
familles n'ont rien pu emporter
quasiment juste le strict nécessaire
dans leur dans leur fuite beaucoup
étaient déjà des personnes vulnérables
vu qu'elles étaient déjà beaucoup été
déjà déplacés elle manque de tout abri
nourriture ou latrines de première
nécessité et ses besoins qui sont vitaux
sont encore
largement ne sont pas du tout couverts
en fait et comme ces gens n'ont pas
accès à leurs champs ils n'ont pas accès
à des sources de revenus ou de dépendre
entièrement de l'aide de l'aide
humanitaire est-ce qu'il y a justement
une aide humanitaire internationale qui
vous parvient en ce moment
bon alors les besoins ils explosent ils
explosent dans le centre de santé
justement à Kanya ruccinia par exemple
nos équipes qui appuient le centre de
santé constate que les
consultats assez de 80 à 180 par jour
effectivement de répondre déjà depuis
ces derniers mois on avait aussi lancé
une activité d'approvisionnement en eau
on a doublé ce weekend la capacité
pour être pour être franc les besoins
ils sont énormes la promiscuité la
saison des pluies qui a lieu pour le
moment
provoque des risques d'infection
respiratoires des risques de choléra de
paludisme et je vous avoue qu'on dépend
un peu une lenteur de la mobilisation
déjà avant c'est des affrontements
secteur certains acteurs sont sur place
le CCR le Palm a fait quelques
distribution mais on est encore très
loin de répondre à l'ensemble des
besoins on espère que les intentions qui
se manifestent pour le moment vont se
traduire en action on est à quelques
kilomètres seulement de Goma ou de
nombreux acteurs humanitaires sont basés
ce serait juste
incompréhensible que la réponse ne soit
pas à la hauteur merci beaucoup Raphaël
Piret pour votre témoignage voilà pour
la situation
sanitaire sur place extrêmement
compliqué puis hier des milliers
d'habitants du
Nord qui vous ont manifesté leur colère
contre cette guerre on va écouter
quelques réactions et puis on va
continuer à en parler évidemment
nous sommes également préoccupé de voir
qu'après 10 ans nous revenons aussi que
les départs avec les mêmes rebelles les
mêmes protagonistes pourtant on était
sûr qu'on avait l'espoir de vivre la
paix durable mais hélas nous demandons à
nos autorités de pouvoir renforcer
l'effectif des phares d'essai pour que
l'option militaire puisse mettre fin à
ce cycle de violence s'il y a des
négociations ce n'est pas grave et sinon
qu'ils utilisent la force l'essentiel
pour nous et de retrouver la paix nous
avons besoin de reprendre nos activités
et que nos enfants grandissent enfin
dans la paix la sécurité
elle victime de multiples agressions du
Rwanda et de l'Ouganda sous la
bénédiction de grande puissance
essentiellement les États-Unis
d'Amérique la Grande-Bretagne la France
et les autres pays
venons par la présence manifestation
estimée au monde entier notre album qui
fait que nous qualifions d'injustice et
des discrimination internationales
contre les Congolais que nous sommes
les Congolais ils en ont marre de cette
situation
là on n'a pas vu sur ces images mais
dans les manifestations notamment hier
certains avaient des photos du président
russe de Vladimir Poutine ils appellent
la Russie à l'aide
c'est finalement pour un appel au
secours alors que la communauté
internationale est impuissante
aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être pas la solution
d'appeler les Russes je pense que c'est
une marque de désespoir
mais si on entend les manifestants dans
le reportage l'appel des manifestants
ils souhaitent peut-être que la France
la Grande-Bretagne des États-Unis puisse
venir les aider mais ils ont tout à fait
raison parce que ce sont des conflits
qui durent depuis très très très
longtemps et que le gouvernement
congolais n'arrive pas ni l'ONU
également qui a sa force là-bas l'une
des plus grandes forces de l'ONU et qui
n'arrive pas à venir à bout de ses
rebelles et il y a des problèmes de
sécurité parce que les populations
veulent vaquer à leurs occupations
veulent aller au marché vendre voilà les
dans les champs vous allez dans les
cérémonies etc ou vivre normalement tout
simplement mais elle n'y arrive pas
parce que tout simplement
des rebelles qui viennent de tout Randa
ou de Rwanda ou qui sont qui habitent
dans dans ces contrées mais qui sont en
connivence avec d'autres
qui sont à l'étranger et que ces
populations ne demandent qu'une chose
c'est vivre normalement voilà on peut en
sécurité
Moscou à l'aide lors de ces
manifestations c'est un aveu d'échec
pour l'ONU et pour les
occidentaux
quand même plusieurs mois à un
changement c'est pour appeler un
changement de paradigme au niveau de la
jeunesse africaine c'est qu'on est
véritablement déçu des relations qui a
eu entre l'Occident et les pays
africains et on essaye de trouver
d'autres alternatives d'autres discours
or Moscou Pékin etc ont des discours qui
parlent à cette jeunesse et ont des
discours et qui répondent entre
guillemets qui prétendent de répondre
aux attentes de cette jeunesse du côté
occidental on n'entend pas vraiment
cette discours des jeunes et qui demande
à ce qu'on puisse changer les rapports
qu'il y avait entre les pays africains
et les pays occidentaux et on se tourne
vers quoi on se tourne vers ce que l'on
pense être pour voir
amener une meilleure réponse une bonne
alternative par rapport à ce qu'on est
en train de vouloir entreprendre
malheureusement c'est ça que l'on est en
train d'assister de plus en plus
et ce courant antioxydant est en train
de gagner eux aussi le Congo et pas que
le Congo
mais d'autres pays pierre Boisselet
je voulais vous faire réagir donc des
appels au secours de la part de la
population
et ces derniers mois aussi les forces de
l'ONU qui ont été prises pour cibles par
la population
quel avenir il y a pour la Monusco 23
ans après son arrivée en RDC on a
l'impression que que la situation
finalement ne s'est pas du tout
améliorée c'est c'est un échec
ah oui clairement en tout cas bon je
pense pas que la Monusco soit la seule
responsable mais en tout cas ces
dernières années effectivement on a vu
dégradation
progressive et presque permanente de la
situation dans l'Est de la RDC donc
effectivement ça crée dimanche
frustrations
chez les
dans la population congolaise bien sûr
et donc on a vu effectivement ces
mouvements de qui s'en sont pris à la
Monusco qui est accusé d'être incapable
inefficace
et donc voilà c'est c'est
essentiellement de la frustration qui se
je dirais déverse vers cette mission
alors effectivement si on a son avenir
aujourd'hui est un peu incertain on sait
qu'il y avait il y a un plan de retrait
mais qui théoriquement devait prendre
encore plusieurs années
il est possible que ce soit
progressivement accéléré
ça dépendra peut-être notamment de la
capacité des pays de l'Afrique de l'Est
à
proposer une force alternative
le Kenya en tout cas a confirmé hier
mercredi que ces troupes étaient prêtes
à être envoyés en RDC pour rejoindre la
force régionale de la communauté
d'Afrique de l'Est on va écouter le
président kenyan William Ruto et puis on
va partir à nairobie dans un instant
wesh la situation dans l'Est de la RDC
reste instable sur le plan opérationnel
et même sur le plan diplomatique
diplomatique
depuis des années la paix échappe à la
RDC en raison de l'insécurité causé par
les groupes armés et les rebelles qui
continuent de s'en prendre aux forces de
sécurité et aux populations civiles
cet état d'insécurité est une
préoccupation majeure pour l'humanité et
pour notre région
à la suite de l'invitation de la RDC
le déploiement d'une force régionale
pour la paix et l'activation de la force
régionale de la communauté de l'Afrique
de l'Est pour prévenir le conflit et
donc légitime
urgent et nécessaire
vous retrouve à nairobie et ce qu'on en
sait un peu plus sur cette force envoyée
par le Kenya l'annonce a donc été faite
hier mercredi
et bien pour tout vous dire j'ai assez
peu d'informations officielles puisque
les autorités kenyan refusent de
communiquer sur le nombre de militaires
ou sur les armes qui vont être employés
dans l'est de la République démocratique
du Congo et sophistiquellement pour des
raisons de sécurité alors si on se fie
au document qui ont été signés par les
différents membres de la Communauté Est
Africaine et bien deux bataillons
gagnants devraient être déployés cela
signifie qu'il y aura entre 600 et 2000
soldats gagnants vous voyez c'est une
fourchette assez large qui seront
envoyés dans l'Est de la RDC hier matin
durant la cérémonie qui a eu lieu
anérobing il y avait plusieurs centaines
de soldats présents il y avait des
camions des véhicules blindés mais
impossible de dire combien seront
envoyés dans l'Est du Congo ce que je
peux vous dire avec un peu plus de
certitude c'est que les troupes kenyan
vont devoir traverser l'Ouganda pour se
rendre en RDC ou elle devrait arriver
dans la ville de bounagana à la
frontière avec l'Ouganda c'est une ville
qui est contrôlée par le M23 l'une des
toutes premières à avoir été prise par
le groupe rebelle et les militaires
craignant devraient intervenir sur
tout à fait oui au total quatre pays
devrait envoyer des troupes sur place un
bataillon sud soudané on ne sait pas
encore où est-ce qu'il va être déployé
deux bataillons gandés deux bataillons
burunday et encore deux bataillons
Kenyans alors les burunders sont
déployés dans le Sud qui vous combattent
des rebelles burunday qui sont déployés
dans cette région de l'Est de la RDC les
Ougandais eux sont présents dans la
région de Beni au sein de la forêt et du
Parc National des Virunga il combattent
le groupe Rebel islamiste des ADF
j'étais d'ailleurs il y a quelques mois
de cela en compagnie des militaires ou
gandés dans la traque de ces ADF et je
peux vous dire que bien leur action sur
le terrain est un petit peu critiqué car
il y a des combats certes mais ils ont
tendance à plus repousser les ADF
qu'elle est capturer qu'elle est
neutralisée et certains Congolais bien
se plaignent que ces troupes ou
gandaises et c'est de les repousser le
plus loin possible de la frontière avec
louendaye est-ce que pour permettre le
rétablissement des relations
commerciales entre la RDC et l'Ouganda
mais qui ne cherchent pas vraiment
vraiment aller neutraliser alors vous le
voyez trois forces différentes qui sont
présentes l'un d'essai déjà au niveau
des pays est africains le Kenya
l'Ouganda le Burundi chacun avec des
objectifs différents alors la question
va être maintenant de savoir s'ils vont
se coordonner pour tenter d'attaquer
ensemble les mêmes groupes comme le M23
qui sévit en ce moment non loin
d'ogomart vous en avez parlé durant tout
le long de cette émission pour l'instant
impossible de le savoir le président
burundai va rester le président en
exercice de la Communauté Est Africaine
a appelé ses homologues de toute la
région hier pour leur demander
d'organiser le plus rapidement possible
une réunion d'urgence avec les états
major des différentes armées et ce
probablement pour ce coordonner ce pour
avoir une réponse plus efficace contre
ces groupes armes merci beaucoup Bastien
renoue notre correspondant à nairobie au
Kenya doudou Sidibé est-ce que cette
force est africaine elle peut changer la
donne sur le terrain absolument si cette
force
coordonne bien c'est à dire les
différents pays qui composent cette
coordonne bien leurs actions
ces pays peuvent venir à bout de ce
mouvement rebelle parce que la
différence avec la Monique c'est que la
monnaie est composée de soldats qui ne
connaissent pas très bien le terrain en
tout cas tous pas tous ce qui viennent
de pays assez lointain il y a des
Pakistanais de banglades qui qui
viennent
au Congo pour combattre les 23 et la
population aussi a du mal à les accepter
à accepter leur présence absolument mais
une force africaine peut faire la
différence parce qu'on est sans mieux le
terrain et puis pouvoir dialoguer aussi
avec la population pour avoir des
informations sur les mouvements aussi de
M23
elle peut faire la différence
est-ce que cette force africaine elle
peut faire la différence
voilà problème de liaison avec Bob
cabamba on essaiera de le retrouver un
petit peu plus tard Pierre Boisselet
est-ce que cette force africaine je vous
pose la question à vous et ce qu'elle
peut faire la différence sur le terrain
aujourd'hui
alors ça dépend ce qu'on appelle faire
la différence on sait que l'est du Congo
est comment dire connaît des conflits de
manière presque continue depuis presque
30 ans maintenant
nous avons recensé plus de 120 groupes
armées différents dans tout l'Est du
Congo donc
je pense si on pense que la
force d'Afrique de l'Est pourrait
résoudre tous ces problèmes je suis un
peu dubitatif peut-être ce qu'elle peut
faire et notamment éventuellement le
contingent kenyang dont on parle c'est
agir sur les crises qui sont vraiment
aigus en ce moment et notamment celle
celle du M23 en fait je pense que
on sait que Félix tsachi avait une
relation très étroite avec l'ancien
président kenyan kenyata et je pense que
confronter à la menace du M23 qui comme
on l'a dit ne peut pas n'arrive enfin en
tout cas là à laquelle l'armée
congolaise n'arrive pas à faire face il
y a eu cette idée de faire appel à
l'armée kenyane bon entre-temps en fait
il y a eu une élection au Kenya et le le
nouveau président n'est pas forcément
celui dont Kenya et le plus proche et
donc il y a encore il y a encore
beaucoup de de questions qui règles qui
restent à régler notamment celle du
financement de cette force on a dit
celle de
son ampleur etc mais voilà c'est je
pense c'est plutôt dans ce cadre là de
de d'être présent sur le terrain face au
M23 et peut-être de d'avoir une présence
qui permette de peser davantage dans les
négociations au niveau régional que ça
pourrait avoir une contribution
en l'espace de 48 heures le président
William Ruto d'abord réticent a envoyé
des soldats finalement il a décidé
d'engager on l'a vu avec notre
correspondant un contingent dans l'Est
de la RDC pourquoi ce changement la
solution a été la situation elle était
vraiment urgente oui en fait je pense
que c'est dans le cas de la Communauté
des États de l'Est et que le Kenya doit
venir en solidarité même si le Kenya
n'est pas directement impacté parce que
entre le Kenya et la RDC l'Ouganda mais
le Kenya doit aider un pays qui en
difficulté et qui appartient à cette
communauté donc je pense que si la RDC
déstabilisé peut-être d'autres pays ça
peut déstabiliser absolument et amené un
conflit
régional comme c'était le cas il y a
quelques années ou plusieurs pays
étaient impliqués Burundi Rwanda Ouganda
Angola tout ça et pour éviter une telle
situation
le président Kenya se doit d'intervenir
depuis Bruxelles l'Union européenne a
multiplié ce week-end les contacts avec
Kinshasa avec Kigali aussi pour essayer
d'arranger les choses les États-Unis ont
fait pareil pierre Boisselet
on a l'impression que la communauté
internationale elle s'agite mais
finalement elle ne fait pas grand-chose
aujourd'hui elle est surtout accaparer
par le conflit en Ukraine
ah oui il y a certainement ça
effectivement
bon il y a des condamnations verbales de
ce qu'il se passe sur le terrain du M23
etc
par contre ce qu'on voit assez peu pour
l'instant c'est des des pressions
concrètes sur le Rwanda qui on l'a dit
et
largement soupçonné d'appuyer le
M23
bon verbalement les États-Unis ont
condamné ce soutien c'est probablement
le pays qui allait le plus loin dans
cette dans cette logique mais pour
l'instant on ne voit pas exactement on
ne voit pas de véritables pression
peut-être il faut rappeler que lors de
la précédente crise du M23 en 2013
les Etats-Unis à l'époque avait exercé
des pressions très fortes sur le Rwanda
et ça avait largement contribué à
affaiblir le M23 jusqu'à jusqu'à sa
défaite finalement
il n'y a pas assez de pression de la
part de la communauté internationale je
pense aux européens notamment il y a eu
une certaine pression de la part des
États-Unis nous disait pierre Boisselet
mais pas forcément les autres pays bon
je pense que le conflit ukrainien est
peut-être et aujourd'hui par le dessus
le temps qu'il mette pour pour régler ce
conflit et ce conflit de M23 se déroule
dans une zone peut-être qui ne modifie
pas réellement la géopolitique mondiale
mais si on laisse
courir ça peut créer aussi d'autres
problèmes notamment des problèmes
humanitaires qui pourraient aussi
être difficile à régler merci beaucoup
merci Doudou Sidibé d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir sur ce plateau merci Pierre
Boisselet vous étiez en direct de Goma
et merci aussi à Bob Kabamba qui était
avec nous et à Raphaël Piret puis à nos
correspondants à nairobie et à Kinshasa
c'est la fin de ce débat vous pouvez le
retrouver sur notre site internet
www.france24.com rester avec nous
l'information continue